bonjour alexis week-end politique chargé
ce week-end on va en parler cette
semaine d'ailleurs emmanuel macron veut
relancer la réforme des retraites il
devrait prendre la parole
quelles pistes sont envisagées et
pourquoi maintenant selon vous oui alors
c'est vrai que haenel macron laisse
planer le doute encore un surtout cette
fameuse réforme des retraites ils
aimeraient la faire passer avant la fin
de son quinquennat sa part et un timing
étonnant compte tenu de la difficulté
qu'il a eues auparavant le 49 3 et puis
le fait qu'aujourd'hui les partenaires
sociaux sont tous contre cette réforme
maintenant que ce n'est pas forcément le
moment qu'elle n'est pas forcément bien
fait le manque de concertation bien
entendu mais ça ça nous n'empêche pas
emmanuel macron de vouloir continuer
l'idée apparemment selon certaines
sources serait de décaler de 62 à 64 ans
l'âge du départ à la retraite ce qui va
à l'encontre des promesses du candidat
macron et donc on voit bien qu'il essaye
d'avoir un bilan à défendre bilan
défendre du côté bien sûr des électeurs
de droite qui pourrait lui reprocher de
n'avoir rien fait et d'avoir fait
semblant mais cela risque d'être
difficile de faire une rentrée sociale
délicate sur fond de covina puisque le
vario delta est là et on ne sait pas où
cela va nous mener le parti présidentiel
qui est affaiblie notamment après les
élections quelle stratégie selon vous
pourrez pour emmanuel macron bien oui
pour emmanuel macron c'est compliqué
mais pour lui la république en marche
est un parti déjà mort un qui ne sert à
rien l'étiquette est plus répulsives
qu'attractive on a vu des députés un peu
gêné d'avoir cette étiquette aux
régionales on essayait de cacher
l'appartenance à la république en marche
le mot d'ordre c'est de faire une maison
commune de faire une nouvelle plateforme
de majorité présidentielle pour emmener
et mener la converse 2022 tout en
changeant le nom de la république en
marche vers autre chose alors il ya déjà
des groupes qui ont fait scission de la
pluie quand marche qui sont maintenant
des groupes qui font partie de la
majorité présidentielle donc on voit
comment tout cela pourrait être fait de
manière assez artificiel autour de lui
des idées du modem d'agir et de ces
groupes qui sont devant l'assemblée
nationale
la réalité c'est que la république en
marche est un parti qui n'arrive pas à
fonctionner à marcher tout simplement
moins de dix mille adhérents alors
certes beaucoup d'argent puisque le
système français fait que les partis
gagnants majoritaire à l'assemblée bien
sont ainsi sur des trésors de guerre
c'est le cas de la république en marche
qui a pu acheter magnifique nouveau
siège dans paris mais en juillet le
congrès arrive et peut-être qu'il y aura
une guerre pour remplacer stanislas
guérini dont le bilan est extrêmement
mitigé avec difficulté bien sûr à
mobiliser des troupes des militants sur
le terrain hors une élection ce n'est
pas uniquement dans les médias ce n'est
pas uniquement un coup de petites
phrases c'est aussi avec des militants
qui vont convaincre au porte à porte
l'idée d'un projet ce qu'elle y avait
beaucoup d'universités d'été a notamment
seul le congrès du rassemblement
national on a une le pen a prononcé son
premier discours de campagne écouter on
en parle après ne reviendrons pas en
arrière
avec tout le respect que nous avons pour
notre propre histoire ne reviendront pas
au front national nous avons su durant
ces dix dernières années nous écarter
des analyses à l'emporte-pièce des
sentence irrévocable et des mesures
simplistes par le travail collectif sans
rien renier des lignes claires de nos
convictions nous avons su nous
affranchir d'une immaturité politique
peu compatible avec des ambitions
nationales et donner à notre mouvement
les qualités nécessaires à un parti de
gouvernement
cette évolution saine et nécessaire
s'incarne aujourd'hui dans ce qu'est
devenu le rassemblement national
alors quels changements précisément pour
le parti de marine le pen alexis très
peu de changements en réalité puisque
leur est reconduite avec une large
majorité à la tête jordan bardella qui
qui prend sa suite on voit bien que la
voie choisie par marine le pen de la
dédiabolisation de de finalement essayé
d'être un parti de gouvernement continue
avec une difficulté tout de même c'était
celle d'attirer de nouveaux cadres
d'attirer autour d'elle davantage de
personnalités qui pourraient former un
gouvernement si elle devait être élue
elle continue sa campagne avec elle
aussi très peu de militants un blues un
des militants du rassemblement national
on l'a vu lors de ces régionales la
défaite était difficile puisque certains
pensaient que la victoire était assurée
dans certaines régions avec aussi des
luttes internes entre l'ancienne garde
la jeu
garde et puis certains comme julien
double portant l'un qui a été téléporté
en bourgogne franche comté et c'était ce
qui est fortement déplu aux militants
locaux
donc on voit que là encore leur
assemblée nationale est un peu comme la
république en marche un parti
extrêmement centralisé un parti avec peu
de militants qui a du mal à s'en crée là
aussi sur les territoires mais aussi
quelques villes sont aujourd'hui à
majorité du reste en national avec à sa
tête
marine le pen qui semble un peu débordée
par sa droite ou une volonté de faire
autre chose que cette voie de la
dédiabolisation qui risque de faire
perdre beaucoup d'électeurs aura 120
national lors des élections de 2022 donc
un congrès là encore en demi-mesure
sans réel grand changement si ce n'est
la continuation et l'entrée dans une
campagne avec on attendra sans doute de
donner aussi longtemps et de deux
nouvelles sections de communication mais
pour ce qui est du programme là encore
le flou persiste puisque c'est
maintenant la mode apparemment de se
présenter à une élection présidentielle
sans programme alors on va on va il nous
reste un petit peu de temps alexis sans
préjuger de rien évidemment demain les
républicains vont aussi se lancer et là
il ya beaucoup de prétendants et il ya
un mot qu'il ne faut pas prononcer ces
primaires alors c'est un peu le ni oui
ni non
il faut dire qu'il y aura quand même une
façon de départager c'est monsieur
leonetti qui était en charge de cet
épineux dossier
comment faire pour trouver le candidat
des républicains sans dire qu'il y aura
une primaire c'est compliqué parce que
les républicains et c'est la droite
puisque certains en font plus plus c'est
la droite
absolument valérie pécresse qui
voudraient y aller qu'il ne fait plus
partie de ce parti xavier bertrand
également qui vient de ce parti et plus
partis donc de ceux qui restent chez les
élèves il y à laurent wauquiez bien
entendu renaud muselier qui a gagné la
région paca mais je ne sais pas s'ils
souhaitent y est allé et d'autres encore
dont on voit toujours ce problème à
droite cette guerre des egos et plus des
chefs et il n'ya plus d'arbitrés des
élégances aujourd'hui c'est chacun pour
soi il faut aller vite puisque xavier
bertrand être déjà candidat il aimerait
être celui qui va emporter tous les
suffrages au sein de sa famille
politique
n'est moins sûr reste à voir évidemment
comment les républicains et au delà la
famille des de droite
plus largement va gérer et trouver un
candidat parce que c'est ce jeu de la
vème république un qui fait que nous les
parties les mouvements sont obligés de
trouver une incarnation un qui va être
hot en cristallisant tourner les
opinions et qui va porter plus qu'un
projet mais une personnalité et parfois
ça peut être un vrai problème pour pour
le parti c'est ce qu'on voit au sein du
ratio national où marine le pen est
contesté mais également au sein de la
france insoumise où certains à gauche
n'aime pas la personnalité de jean-luc
mélenchon parce que voilà comment le jeu
dans la vème république fonctionnent il
faut hyper personnaliser ce scrutin au
finalement aux dépens du débat politique
des idées et des programmes
jean luc mélenchon dont le parc le
meeting a été un peu perturbée par le
mauvais temps
par contre oui il a pu les empêcher
jean luc mélenchon de tenir son meeting
à l'extérieur pour des raisons de
sécurité puisque révélé des risques
orageux donc il a tenu son meeting en
intérieur en donnant rendez vous au
prochain au livre cd d'été en de la
france insoumise delà il y aura le grand
rassemblement en août pour compter les
troupes et partir bien sûr en campagne à
ce moment là avec encore davantage
davantage d'organisations
là encore jean luc mélenchon a choisi la
version marathon de la campagne
présidentielle puisqu'il est parti très
tôt avec des pétitions en ligne avec la
base programmatique de l'avenir en
commun
qui porte c'est la troisième fois qu'il
se présente à l'élection présidentielle
c'est un mec aussi l'espoir de jean luc
mélenchon d'être celui qui arrivera à
mettre derrière lui des forces de gauche
mais on voit que c'est compliqué puisque
à gauche et elle a encore beaucoup de
candidatures qui arrive la primaire pour
élever le parti des écologistes avec
yannick jadot sandrine rousseau eric
piolle ans qu'ils sont sur la ligne de
départ
et puis au parti socialiste alors là
c'est la tante may grande attente se
rase anne hidalgo as qu'arnaud
montebourg va faire quelque chose même
si lui a acquitté ou c a pris ses
distances avec le parti socialiste est
encore plein d'autres qui pourraient
entrer dans la course qui ne sont pas
des quarts et donc l'automne sera très
très occupé avec un embouteillage de
candidats sans doute absolument à
l'instar de nicolas dupont aignan dont
on va parler d'ailleurs dans l'interview
politique
à 8 heures merci beaucoup alexis poulain
pour cet édito ce matin dans la matinale
verte et france